you know it's funny how Nikola Tesla and
Einstein spoke in detail about intuition
and what it did for them and their works
and yet we hear almost nothing about
intuition or even Nikola Tesla in school
or anywhere else in our society and we
can all thank Tesla for literally 80% of
all of our modern technology it all
results back to his inventions and his
lifelong works and achievement yet
there's almost a suppression of anything
about Tesla within our school systems
and our society as a whole
Tesla himself stated that intuition is
what led to all of his achievements that
he would literally imagine things in his
mind all of his inventions
before he would ever do any practical
work in a laboratory and it's incredible
to think that of all these amazing
inventions that he came up with he was
able to do it in just his head how do
you explain that whereas you have Thomas
Edison who jokes about all I found
10,000 ways not to do something now real
quick let me correct myself for my prior
video about Tesla that Thomas Edison he
didn't invent the light bulb he
purchased the patent and then had his
freaking interns go do all the work for
him and he stamped his name on it at the
end of it he was not a brilliant
inventor he was a brilliant marketer and
a fraud
and I also mentioned any failed to pay
Tesla ten thousand dollars well it turns
out it's actually 50 thousand dollars
and if utilized an inflation calculator
you'll see that it equates to millions
of dollars in today's money Edison is a
dirtbag now to get back on the subject
of intuition many people from all
different spectrums of industry fields
and different periods of time throughout
history have spoken about intuition
whether it be Oprah or Ralph Waldo
Emerson or even Aristotle and many many
others and it's interesting to mention
that Aristotle was trained by Plato in
Plato was trained by Socrates now
Socrates was an incredible influence on
Steve Jobs and Steve Jobs even stated
that he would trade all of his
technology for an afternoon with
Socrates and he wasn't joking
and you may not be aware of Steve Jobs
his thoughts on intuition for example he
stated intuition is a very powerful
thing more powerful than intellect in my
opinion which is exactly what Einstein
and Tesla said themselves he also stated
much of what I stumbled into by
following my curiosity and intuition
turned out to be priceless later on in
one last quote by ohm he said have the
courage to follow your heart and
intuition they somehow already know what
you truly want to become everything else
is secondary
here's another quote by Nikola Tesla my
brain is only a receiver in the universe
there is a core from which we obtain
knowledge strength and inspiration
I have not penetrated into the secrets
of this core but I know that it exists
now something that Tesla and Einstein
both had in common were their thoughts
on frequency and vibration and energy
that essentially they were describing
what we now know are atoms and when you
study atoms you learn that it's this
mysterious energy that science cannot
explain yet it is the building blocks of
everything that we have but to further
the discussion of frequency we know that
there's millions of colors that the
human eye can even register they're just
out of the frequency of our field of
vision that the human eyes and the veil
of the human eyes can register however
take infrared as an example you'll have
these nature shows that go out in pitch
black and set up these huge infrared
lamps that to the naked eye look like
they're just turned off they're not
doing anything but when you use
technology on the right frequency it
lights everything up like it's a stadium
so just because our human eyes can't see
or understand something doesn't mean
it's not there we know this I mean even
take for example our human body and all
the different elements that it's made up
of you can't see the iron metal in your
blood but you sure can taste and smell
it and through science we can detect
that it is there that literally your
blood contains metal iron now scientists
will say oh well let's trace them out
and it's measured in parts per million
it's practically negligible really so
without iron in our blood would you even
be alive No so it's not negligible it's
a key ingredient and what's even crazier
when you look into all the elements that
our body's made up of you see that we
have copper cobalt and we're mostly made
up of carbon which is incredible yet we
can go on our bodies I mentioned this in
my other video about Tesla that despite
being coming from being made of dirt or
Stardust or whatever you want to call it
same thing in my in my book we are able
to create instruments from various
elements the dirt the ground metal and
yet these instruments can create music
that we love I mean how do you explain
music where does that
- what we need for strong to survive or
evolution or anything like that
where I also mentioned love before love
has no place in how the workings of
science claim that you know with our
evolution everything it's a missing link
and I firmly believe that laughter love
music are all examples of the quote
unquote I'm going to call it divinity or
that our body is essentially the earth
and our mind is the source of all things
that we're connected to it and it's
evidence of it let me touch on humor we
will agree that humor is very culturally
right there what's funny on one side the
country or one side the world will
differ and people won't find certain
things funny throughout the worlds that
they'll find funny in their own culture
but yet something that's universally
funny almost in every culture around the
world is when somebody trips and falls
and eats it you know on a flat surface
and assuming that they're not hurt but
people will laugh at that people will
laugh at themselves from tripping and
falling and others will laugh at them
and I think that it is evidence of our
subconscious that's tied to the universe
that our bodies are essentially our
consciousness occupies our bodies like
an avatar robot whatever you want to
call it don't take those words too
literally but I do think that we our
body is a vessel or vehicle of some kind
and that it's a subconscious humor that
when we see ourselves mess up something
stupid like just tripping and falling
it's funny yet how do you explain that
why is that funny and what is funny what
is humor what is that when you really
think about it it's pretty interesting
and it's pretty mind-blowing and in my
opinion it's evidence of that there's
something going on beyond the veil of
our eyes this ties into another quote by
Tesla every living being is an engine
geared to the wheel work of the universe
so seemingly affected only by its
immediate surrounding the sphere of
external influence extends to infinite
distance so let me explain this in an
analogy that I made up an octopus one of
the smartest creatures on planet earth
it's brain isn't just centrally located
in its head but in fact eight of its
tentacles all eight of its tentacles
have the brainstem and nerve and
essentially every single legs tentacle
can operate individually by itself all
at the same time every single suction
cup and they have hundreds of them which
is pretty incredible considering that
most humans can't even juggle right yet
octopus can utilize this intelligence to
squeezed through a one inch diameter
hole despite being a giant octopus or
even take this picture in the lower
right corner of that small little
rectangular hole that that octopus is
able to squeeze out of and it's not just
because it doesn't have bones in its
body it's because it's able to maneuver
every single piece of its body all at
the same time now I see ur eyes that
this analogy is sort of like the works
of the universe that we are
consciousness that there is a one
consciousness that we are all tied to
and that we're just a small piece of it
we're a piece of the tentacle so to
speak of the will work of the universe
that Tesla spoke about let me give you
another example of this Universal
intelligence we can find it in nature if
you're not familiar with the Fibonacci
sequence of numbers or they're also
called golden ratios you can see that
there are patterns found throughout
nature whether in trees and how they
grow and how they stem off or in bushes
or in various fruits and vegetables and
you can find examples of this everywhere
and that there are certain ratios in
certain number patterns that clearly
show that there is some sort of
intelligence behind nature and that
everything isn't just random and that
things just nature just is chaotic and
just work on itself that clearly they
show and if you go testing this for
yourself and go out in nature and look
at the trees and the bushes you will see
for yourself that holy crap there is a
pattern and that there's an intelligence
behind this pattern there's no other way
but I think that another example of this
universal intelligence and that evidence
that we are literally tied to a one
consciousness is the subject of
synchronicity now Carl Jung is
considered the father of analytic
psychology and he's the one that coined
the term synchronicity and it's
something that he explored in depth
through the latter part of his life now
one example of this is where he had a
client on his couch in his office and
she was explaining a dream she had the
night before of where she received a
golden Sheryl necklace and at that exact
moment a golden roach of some kind
beetle where every Polish Arab started
pinning at the window right behind him
on there on the second floor and it was
incredible the timing because one he had
never seen an insect like that his
office ever before in the habit of that
precise timing another example of this
is on the one-year anniversary of 9/11
the New York lottery had their pick
three in are you aware that a 9/11 2002
the three numbers
came up was 9-1-1 for real that actually
happened and there was more than 1500
winners another crazy example of
synchronicity involves a French poet in
1800s where he had purchased plum
pudding for the first time from a street
vendor and he loved it now fast-forward
10 years later he's in the restaurant
and he sees that they have plum pudding
on the menu he's like oh my god I gotta
order that well when he tells the server
that he would go over to the plum
pudding he the server inform him that oh
we're sorry the last order order had
just been sold to the gentleman at the
table next to you is there something
else he can get you well he looks over
and he sees that the guy who ordered the
last plum pudding was the same exact
street vendor that served him the plum
pudding the very first time crazy right
now fast forward 17 years later the same
gentleman is in a restaurant with some
friends and he's looking at the dessert
menu is like oh my god they have plum
pudding and it reminds him of that story
so he starts telling the story to his
buddies and at that exact moment the
same street vendor who is now seen old
and senile walks in through the front
door at that exact moment but what are
the odds of that now I've had my own
miraculous moments of synchronicity in
my life and I could sit here I'm sharing
with you but it's like look
seeing is believing you need to see
things for yourself if you're not
familiar with synchronicity all you have
to do is open your mind to the same
frequency to the right frequency and
you'll be able to see these things for
yourself it's amazing what you can do if
you just ask the universe for something
I'm not kidding
your word says power say it out loud
universe send me signs and
synchronicities to show me that there's
crazy things happening behind the scenes
where does anyway you want say I am
going to see synchronicities Carl Jung
one thing that he discovered even though
he couldn't figure out what
synchronicities were was that the more
that you pay attention to him the more
that you become aware of synchronicities
the more that they will happen in your
life and I have seen synchronistic
moments that were so miraculous and that
they would double down in the exact
moment afterwards even when your jaws
already dropped that they are firsthand
miracles to prove to you firsthand that
there is crazy things happening in this
universe and it all ties back into
intuition all of these things the real
works of the universe your consciousness
is literally dialed into the universal
energies out there your body is the
earth your mind is of the source guys
test we'll figure this out that's how he
was able to create so much
incredible inventions with just his
brain and there's other examples of this
to take for example near-death
experiences which I'm going to do a
video on at some point where there's
being studies being done involving
thousands of people that were medically
verified to have died on the operating
table heart stopped brain dead and yet
to come back miraculously but yet when
they come back they're able to share
things and experiences that they had
there weren't possible being brain dead
that they exceed the realm of just being
a dream while they're between
consciousness where there see I mean
this one example this lady had bled out
on the operating table
she comes back miraculously and while
she was dead she met her grandfather who
had died when she was a kid who was a
doctor and he said hey look you tell
them when you wake up that you have
three infections one of which is in your
pancreas tell them so she wakes up is
blurting out how she has this infection
and she saw her grandfather like what
long story short day and a half later
they have run a bunch of tests on her
doctor comes in a day and half later and
says oh my god yeah you actually did
have an infection in your pancreas and
thank God there will fix it and save her
life this is just one little example of
many but the bottom line is that there
is clearly a realm that exceeds what
your physical 3d human eyes can see and
that you can source energy to give to
maximize your intuition to help improve
your life and improve this world Tesla
did it
Einstein figured it out although Tesla I
think has it clearly had an edge on him
on how we was able to utilize it anyways
guys I'll close up there I'm Jimmy this
is bright insight like and subscribe
help me spread the message I have many
other videos and a whole wide variety of
topics take care everybody